i am the biggest tom holland zendaya
freakazoid
[Music]
well i'm excited because it is
apparently the 20th anniversary of the
film a walk to remember what oh my gosh
of course with mandy moore nicholas
sparks
shane west every oh well there you go i
remember this movie i'm still i'm still
recovering from this movie it was so sad
well people reports that mandy moore
wouldn't mind seeing a remake and she
even said she really wishes to see
olivia rodrigo i love her
because
she's a great actress she has beautiful
pipes i love that that's so sweet and
like endearing um yeah because if i had
a classic movie i i'd wanted to remake
it i'd be like no i already did it it
was perfect thank you so you don't need
to do that
well first up roxy we have got some huge
box office news it looks like spider-man
no way home is about to become the
highest grossing movie of all time wow
you think about that
there are 20 million away from
surpassing avatar which made 760 million
at the box office and buzzfeed reports
the tom holland oh i love him so much
got the news live while doing an
interview for his new movie uncharted i
mean i just love tom holland so much i
recently posted this picture because i
actually met him
many years ago
for a general meeting for a film i was
directing and he was the loveliest i am
the biggest tom holland zendaya
freakazoid
all right well next i don't know about
you ross but my eyeballs are deep into
the olympics right now and i am just so
into it and this news is very important
nbc reports that the u.s olympic team
includes 222 athletes and 108 of them
are women and that is the most
female athlete for any nation
in the history of the winter olympics
now this is the 11th consecutive time
the us has broken their own record we
started breaking it back in 1984 with 30
women athletes so from 30 to 108
i think we've come a long way and this
should be the standard yes it should be
and
are you watching are you watching the
olympics 100
i am obsessed i watched it with my
daughters and they had a sleepover so
like
all me and the girls were piled like
little sardines in the bed and we
watched um nathan chen and all the
figure skating
you know i could have been a figure
skater if i would have gone back in time
it's such a shame you know i do have
petite ankles i told you so i can't do
it i can't stay up by the way you have
the ankles i want
they are the only part of my body that's
always at my goal weight
next a new study confirms something we
already know america loves road trips oh
please yes
again this is another story i can get
really behind people reports a new
survey of 2000 drivers found 76 of them
would pick driving over flying if they
knew the drive would be enjoyable and 74
said the journey is more important than
the destination and 78 said that they
found hidden gems along the way that
they would have never found otherwise
and more than half said that the perfect
road trip buddy is their partner that's
fortunate um and a lot of people also in
this uh survey said that a spontaneous
road trip can be equally if not more
enjoyable than a planned road trip raw
thought well okay i want to be very
clear i find driving in traffic to be
outrageous like i get like stressed out
about it that being said i love to dilly
and i love to dally and so if we could
go on a road trip and just take our time
and explore sign me up other thing i
love about road trips i thought a lot
about this snacks can we talk about road
trip snacks
give me a big gulp which i know means
we're gonna stop a few times but i don't
care i want that big gulp
[Music]
you